und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend die woche der politik hat nur noch
einen bürotag und es laufen allmählich
fristen ab am montag soll eine neue
ministerpräsidentin konferenz bei der
kanzlerin endlich die beschlüsse fassen
die letztes mal nicht zu erreichen waren
sie werde nicht zwei wochen zuschauen
wie nichts gemacht wird hat die
kanzlerin gesagt am sonntag sind die
zwei wochen vorbei da wäre doch dieser
donnerstag ein guter tag gewesen um
schon mal einen ausweg zu bahnen aus dem
wahrhaftig ungesunden stillstand den
klaus brodbeck beschreibt und danach
beschreibt wolfgang schäuble ein
notausgang der nur noch eine mehrheit
bräuchte es sind treffen der macht alle
länder dazu der bund mehr auf einmal
geht nicht alles gegen krohne die idee
miteinander die realität durcheinander
und frust selbst bei jenen die dabei
sind
ich finde wir sollten die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz sinnvoll
vorbereiten und zwar strukturiert
vorbereiten dazu braucht es auch
vorlagen und dann kann es auch zu
gemeinsamen beschlüssen kommen
im moment geht es mir vor allem darum
dass die beschlüsse die da sind
umgesetzt werden und zwar in jedem
bundesland und da kam mir schon ganzen
schritt weiter in deutschland ich bin
nach wie vor sehr vorsichtig ich weiß
dass wir auch noch jede menge risiken
haben
aber ich glaube dass eine stetige
verlässliche politik derzeit vielmehr
nutzt als wenn wir jetzt sozusagen
wieder in diesen kurzatmigen aktionismus
verfallen den wir vor ostern hatten die
macht macht fast nichts für viele
jedenfalls zu wenig und von video
konferenz zu video konferenz wird klar
wie schwer sie sich tot
dieses verfahren hat sich nicht bewährt
dieses verfahren führt nicht zu
verlässlichkeit transparenz und
rechtssicherheit sondern das richtige
verfahren dafür ist hier der
gesetzgebungsprozess im parlament 52
abgeordnete der unionsfraktion forderten
heute per brief ähnliches es ist eine
frage unserer verantwortung als
bundesgesetzgeber dem bund zusätzlich
dieselben handlungsmöglichkeiten zu
geben wie den ländern
die zeit drängt mit jedem zu warten
werden die schäden größer
die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist
noch nicht einmal technisch vorbereitet
geschweige denn inhaltlich einig was sie
will und deswegen zeigt sich immer mehr
wir brauchen eine regelungskompetenz des
bundes werden glaubt dass wenn die
bundeskanzlerin nur richtig durchgreifen
kann besiegen wir die pandemie der irrt
ich weiß noch nicht ob frau merkel dann
gegebenenfalls panzer im saarland
schicken will
das alles ist einigermaßen absurd aus
meiner sicht doch es wird in berlin
ernsthaft erwogen in einem gutachten in
auftrag gegeben von bundestagspräsident
wolfgang schäuble kommt der
wissenschaftliche dienst des parlamentes
zu der beurteilung der bund können die
maßnahmen zur bekämpfung der korona
pandemie vollumfänglich gesetzlich
regeln bei entsprechender gestaltung
bliebe den ländern dabei kaum eigene
spielraum
es ist politisch unklug dass gegen den
bundesrat durchsetzen zu wollen denn
wenn tempo das thema der stunde ist dann
führt selbst dann wenn der bundestag ist
ohne den bundesrat könnte immer dazu
dass der bundesrat das verfahren
verzögern könnte ehrlich gesagt wird es
das nicht geben weil eine solche
entscheidung ja auch die mehrheit im
bundesrat benötigte und die länder
werden einer in anführungsstrichen
entmachtung niemals zustimmen
sie wehren sich dann wenigstens einig
die für montag geplante
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz könnte
übrigens verschoben werden von einigkeit
hier keine spur
mitten in der dritten besonders
gefährlichen welle der pandemie werden
sich 17 regierungschefs von bund und
ländern nicht einig und wursteln
notgedrungen irgendwie weiter einen
schönen guten abend herr
bundestagspräsident wann wenn nicht
jetzt müsse der bund und damit auch der
bundestag verantwortung übernehmen
herr kleber nachdem die
ministerpräsidenten selber gesagt haben
dass die form in der man das bisher in
unserem föderalen system nicht gemacht
hat spricht sehr viel dafür dass wir das
stärker durch bundesgesetz machen und
wenn das der wunsch im bundestag ist
wenn die mehrheit des so beschließt dann
können wir ja gesetzlich entweder die
bundesregierung ermächtigen dazu braucht
man dann eine zustimmung des bundesrats
oder wir können bestimmte regeln für die
länder verbindlich vorgeben durch
bundesgesetz das muss ja nicht einmal im
bundesrat zustimmung finden
sie haben ja selbst durch anforderungen
einer rechtlichen expertise alle
abgeordneten noch einmal darauf gestutzt
und gesagt ihr habt diese möglichkeit
und sie sollten das nutzen um stärker
verantwortung zu übernehmen heißt das
der bundestag hat bisher zu schwach
verantwortung übernommen
nein das würde ich nicht sagen wir haben
ja auch das infektionsschutzgesetz im
november deutlich auf die pandemie lage
angepasst und im grunde ist ja die
arbeitsteilung zwischen gesetzgeber der
nur allgemeine regeln machen kann und
regierungen die die einzelnen
regierungen die die entscheidungen im
einzelnen treffen müssen durchaus
richtig in der auch im rahmen der
gewaltenteilung auch im föderalismus
aber wenn die länder nun selber sagen
dass sie sich nicht einigen können und
es ist ja inzwischen doch einigermaßen
sichtbar geworden und wenn daraus eine
solche verunsicherung in einer
schwierigen phase in teilen der
öffentlichkeit eintritt dann spricht in
der tat viel dafür zu sagen dann lass es
uns ein stück weit weiter einheitlich
und das kann nun in der tat der
bundestag tun wenn er es somit mehrheit
beschließt sie sollten aber was ist das
das wird was kosten was niemand hat
nämlich viel zeit das geht doch nicht
von heute auf morgen oder wäre das
möglich ganz schnell wie damals bei den
griechenland hilfen
das kann auch schnell gehen wir werden
ja nicht jedes detail regeln das wäre ja
sicher auch falsch das muss ja in den
einzelnen städten gemeinden landkreisen
immer noch auf die situation ein stück
weit angepasst werden aber wenn man zum
beispiel sagt ab einer bestimmten zahl
von infektionen müssen bestimmte
maßnahmen ergriffen werden
das haben ja die minister die
regierungschefs auch so verabredet und
sich geschworen sie halten sich alle
dran und haben es dann unterschiedlich
interpretiert das kann man in der tat
gesetzlich festlegen und es kann auch
schnell gehen
das heißt der bundestag müsste im grunde
nur die beschlüsse die dann nicht so
richtig eingehalten wurden von den
ministerpräsidenten
praktisch zu einem bundesgesetz
verarbeiten wo dann nicht für alle diese
maßnahmen stehen aber für alle derselbe
maßstab zum beispiel ab einer bestimmten
incidents passiert die so dass das heißt
der bund würde praktisch die
zentralgewalt übernehmen und den
ministerpräsidenten zeigen wie es geht
nein nicht den ministerpräsidenten
zeigen wie es geht es wäre ja völlig
überheblich die an die erfahrung die
haben die erfahrung wie es vor ort geht
man ihr helfen januar das ist ja auch
subsidiär subsidiarität richtig
verstandene wenn die ministerpräsidenten
nach jeder ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
dann hinterher doch wieder irgendwie
unterschiedlich wirken und es auch
beklagen vor jeder
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und auch
appellieren sie sollen es alle
einheitlich machen dann können wir als
gesetzgeber ihnen dabei doch ein ganzes
stück weit helfen
das heißt die kontrolle müsste den
ministerpräsidenten insofern von berlin
gegeben werden dass sie ihre eigenen
beschlüsse einhalten meinen sie dass das
praktikable politik ab montag sein kann
wenn nichts anderes zu stande kommt im
moment steht ja nicht mal der termin für
die montägliche
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
naja da zb diese frage ja offenbar noch
nicht so richtig geklärt es gibt ja
ministerpräsidenten die sich offenbar
auch für dieses verfahren ausgesprochen
haben macht es ja durchaus sinn zu sagen
man muss übrigens auch mit den
fraktionen sprechen der bundestag
entscheide durch die mehrheit im
bundestag da muss man mit den fraktionen
reden
die müssen das diskutieren die machen
das ja nicht einfach weil die regierung
einen gesetzentwurf vorlegt das muss
schon bedacht werden
deswegen kann man das ja miteinander
vertrauensvoll besprechen wie sie ist
der föderalismus erfordert und wenn man
sich wenn man das dann will dann kann
man das in den beiden nächsten
sitzungswoche oder zur not auch in einer
sitzungswoche schnell verabschieden wenn
man es nur auf regeln die dann von den
ländern einheitlich umzusetzen ist
beschränkt dann bedarf es gar nicht der
zustimmung des bundesrats natürlich ist
ein einspruchgesetz der bundesrat kann
einspruch einlegen aber das kann schnell
gehen wenn die beteiligten alle wollen
wir werden sehen dass was geschieht das
angebot des bundestags präsidentin steht
danke schön herr schäuble das gespräch
hatten wir etwa um halb neun ein jahr
pandemie kämpfen das heißt auch ein jahr
zig milliarden hilfe für die deutsche
wirtschaft die für die pandemie ja
nichts kann sie aber unbedingt überleben
muss vielen unternehmen die es heute gar
nicht mehr geben würde ist geholfen
worden
aber nicht allen und nicht allen gerecht
und nicht für alle schnell genug
es wurden fehler gemacht und gelder
fehlgeleitet und jetzt wird noch mehr
geld gebraucht das virtuelle treffen von
über 40 wirtschaftsverbänden heute beim
wirtschaftsminister war kein gipfel das
war eher eine klagemauer an der nicht
gebetet wurde sondern gefordert dominik
müller roussel erlebt diese geschichte
durch die augen eines unternehmens
dessen branche die pandemie mit als
erstes getroffen hat
messeservice ist das geschäft der firma
melles und stein aus erkrath bei
düsseldorf das heißt sie organisieren
und betreiben messestände im auftrag
ihrer kunden vor 23 jahren gegründet von
silke melles und nicole stein gehört ihr
messeservice unternehmen zu den drei
größten in deutschland noch den seit
langem steht alles still
wir sind seit 13 monaten im lok da und
wir haben seit 13 monaten 100%
umsatzausfall und wenn es nicht
irgendwann bald weitergeht dann wird es
die firma mehlis und steinen auch
irgendwann nicht mehr geben irgendwann
sind die mittel dann erschöpft wenn ich
der regierungen zeugnis ausstellen
müsste für die bisherigen hilfen und die
unterstützung würde sich wahrscheinlich
als arbeitgeber darauf zu einem stets
bemüht aber leider hat bisher zu wenig
wirklich konsequent und sinnvoll
umgesetzt worden beispiel test strategie
die firma melles und stein hat einen
teil ihrer büroräume freigeräumt für ein
neues corona schnelltests zentrum
vorteil sie können dadurch ihre
laufenden kosten etwas minimieren und es
gibt dadurch mehr test kapazitäten die
vielleicht dazu führen dass früher
wieder geöffnet werden kann
doch keine so guten nachrichten vom
testzentrums betreiber viele unternehmen
und betriebe mit denen er kontakt hat
entscheiden sich noch gegen regelmäßige
tests für ihre mitarbeiter sehr zum
unmut von mails und stein
wir sind seit 13 monaten in zwangs
lockdown in unserem geschäft und wir
wünschen uns natürlich nichts mehr als
dass es mit dem impfen und dem testen
vorangeht damit wir irgendwann wieder
eine perspektive haben und ich finde da
müssen die unternehmen die hat noch
arbeiten dann vielleicht auch einfach
ein bisschen solidarität walten lassen
und sagen ich lasse meine leute testen
das wenn das meine größte sorge wäre ich
muss machen die leute testen lassen dann
wäre ich froh beispiel staatliche hilfen
zum einen empfinden sie es als eine art
glücksspiel sagen sie welches
unternehmen wann was bekommt und zum
anderen sind die anträge für die hilfen
so kompliziert dass selbst der
steuerberater kaum noch hinterher kommt
der teufel steckt im detail vor allem in
den faq den frequently asked questions
zu den eigentlichen anträgen
mittlerweile ändern effekte sich alle
ein zwei manchmal drei wochen aber
manchmal nur geringfügig aber manchmal
auch relativ umfassend
also muss praktisch jeden tag am ball
bleiben weil es immer sein kann dass
sich etwas ändert verlässlichkeit
wünschen sie sich vor allem auch eine
verlässliche eröffnungspartie 'we mit
größeren messen rechnen mails und stein
nicht vor 2022 bis dahin wollen sie
durchhalten hätte uns einer am anfang
der krise gesagt das dauert zwei jahre
ob wir dann gesagt hätten kein problem
das weiß ich nicht aber so will man
natürlich jetzt hat man so lange
durchgehalten jetzt möchte man auch gern
auch da sein wenn es weiter geht
also jetzt auf den letzten metern
aufgeben wäre halt auch ganz schön blöd
ihre branche hat es als allererste
getroffen nun endlich müssen die korona
konzepte aufgehen sagen sie sonst war
alles umsonst
viel glück kann man so jemand nur
wünschen nachrichten von gundula gause
trotz der pandemie finden die
abiturprüfungen in diesem jahr statt das
beschloss die kultusministerkonferenz
ebenso wie grundsätzlich einen
öffnungskurs mit mehr testmöglichkeiten
kindern und jugendlichen solle ihre
lebenswelt zurückgegeben werden
vor allem abschlussklassen sollen in den
präsenzunterricht allerdings
verzichteten die minister auf
einheitliche maßnahmen
nordrhein-westfalen zum beispiel will
nach den osterferien am nächsten montag
im distanz unterricht starten
in einem telefonat mit dem russischen
präsidenten putin hat bundeskanzlerin
merkel über die verstärkte russische
militärpräsenz nahe der ost ukraine
gesprochen und dabei zurückhaltung
eingefordert putin wies vorwürfe
deutlich zurück und machte die ukraine
für die zunehmenden spannungen in der
region verantwortlich
der ukrainische präsident elends
gereiste heute in die konfliktgebiete wo
erneut ein regierung soldat ums leben
kam
seit jahresbeginn sind bei
schusswechseln mit prorussischen
separatisten 50 menschen getötet worden
in nordirland haben protestantische und
katholische politiker die anhaltenden
gewalttätigen ausschreitungen scharf
verurteilt auch der britische premier
johnson rief zu mäßigung auf in der
sechsten krawallnacht in folge wurde in
belfast ein linienbus in brand gesetzt
mehrere polizisten wurden verletzt
die behörden machen militante
protestantische gruppen verantwortlich
sie lehnen den br- exit sonderstatus
nordirlands ab und die damit verbundenen
importkontrollen für aus großbritannien
eingeführte waren us präsident biden
will mit einer reihe von erlassen die
waffengewalt in den usa unter kontrolle
bringen
jährlich sterben dort zehntausende durch
schusswaffen
ein grund zur scham erklärte beiden
zunächst will er gegen unregistrierte
sogenannte geister waffen vorgehen
die als bausätze im internet bestellt
werden
können käufer sollen künftig überprüft
werden versuche der us demokraten die
waffengesetze zu verschärfen scheitern
seit jahrzehnten an der us waffenlobby n
a
und den republikanern der europäische
gerichtshof für menschenrechte hält eine
impfpflicht für kinder rechtens geklagt
hatten mehrere familien aus tschechien
wo kinder verpflichtend gegen neuen
krankheiten wie keuchhusten und masern
geimpft werden müssen
das sei im besten interesse der kinder
und kein verstoß gegen das recht auf
achtung des privat und familienlebens
urteilte das gericht
gesundheitsminister sparen will ohne die
eu mit russland über mögliche
lieferungen des corona impfstoffes
sputnik wie sprechen bayern und
mecklenburg vorpommern haben bereits
eigenständig vorverträge geschlossen
über mehrere millionen dosen des
russischen vakzins bevor sputnik wie
eingesetzt werden könne müsse es
zunächst durch die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde ema zugelassen
werden betonte spahn
zudem müsse geklärt werden wie viel
impfstoff russland kurzfristig liefern
können
brasilien ein land von 210 millionen
menschen ein land voller schätze und
wunder sollte eine treibende kraft des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts werden
und ist zum höllenloch der pandemie
geworden
außer in indien breitet sich nirgendwo
sonst das virus schneller aussterben tag
für tag mehr menschen daran und der
staatschef weigert sich die krise ernst
zu nehmen
das ist nicht nur eine brasilianische
tragödie
das land droht eine brutstätte weiterer
mutationen zu werden
die fittesten unter ihnen wird die welt
irgendwann kennenlernen christoph röcke
rat ist für uns in rio de janeiro josé
zeigt was er nicht was es hier gibt nur
ein bisschen wasser zum trinken und die
schränke da sind auch leer nur töpfe
nicht zu
rosé und seine familie leben in einem
armenviertel in rio de janeiro
sie gehören zu den vielen millionen
brasilianern die nicht wissen was sie
morgen auf dem tisch haben werden seit
beginn der pandemie steigt die armut
fast jeder zehnte hungert sogar das
virus breitet sich aus die wirtschaft
bricht ein hilfsgelder reichlich
millionen brasilianer stecken in der
falle
die einzige lösung wäre die im anker
menschen doch solange das nicht der fall
ist muss man ihnen wenigstens
ermöglichen sicherheitsabstand
voneinander zu halten und zu hause
das impfprogramm stockt und präsident
von solar oder das virus von anfang an
verharmlost hat wehrt sich weiter gegen
die empfehlungen der wissenschaft er
macht stimmung gegen lok dauern
maßnahmen regionaler regierungen und hat
die hilfszahlungen reduziert brasilien
dürfe nicht still stehen sagt er
es wird keinen nationalen lockdown geben
politisch so unter druck scheuen die
meisten städte einen konsequenten lok
tor und so zwängen sich jeden tag
millionen menschen in überfüllte
verkehrsmittel um zu arbeiten
sie haben keine wahl wenn ich nicht
arbeite habe ich nichts zu essen kann
die miete nicht bezahlen ich muss meine
familie ernähren und dafür in einer
dreckigen bus mein leben riskieren die
zahlen der infizierten und toten steigen
in einem nie dagewesenen tempo
im märz starben doppelt so viele
menschen wie im februar
das gesundheitswesen ist längst
überlastet selbst den toten lässt das
virus keine ruhe
auf ihrem friedhof im norden von sao
paulo müssen sie raus aus ihren gräbern
um platz zu schaffen für jene die
täglich zu tausenden sterben sie
befinden uns in der schlimmsten
denkbaren menschen werden ärmer
denn forscher warnen dass es bei der
ungebremste vermehrung des virus nur
eine frage der zeit sei bis neue
mutanten entstünden die irgendwann sogar
die wirkung der impfstoffe aushebeln
können
schon jetzt verbreitet sich die
gefährlichere variante p1 von brasilien
aus in alle welt wo die internationale
gemeinschaft wie es bewirken könnt und
was auch in der praxis impfen und den
armen helfen um die welt zu schützen
alles hängt zusammen im angesicht dieser
globalen pandemie nachrichten aus der
wirte in der korona zeit legen
hierzulande immer mehr menschen wert auf
ein eigenes zuhause die nachfrage nach
immobilien und baufinanzierungen nimmt
weiter zu und das trotz steigender
preise frank bethmann pandemie bedingte
wirtschaftlicher unsicherheiten
schrecken interessenten offenbar nicht
nein ganz und gar nicht weil neben den
annehmlichkeiten mehr platz zu haben
eventuell sogar mit einem großen garten
schlicht und ergreifend die weiterhin
extrem niedrigen zinsen locken baugeld
ist halt billig und so entwickelte sich
das gruner jahr 2020 zu einem boom ja in
sachen baufinanzierungen 273 milliarden
euro nahmen die immobilienkäufer an neu
darlehen auf ein rekordvolumen ein
rekordvolumen auch weil die immobilien
von monat zu monat teurer werden und die
kaufinteressenten deshalb immer höhere
hypotheken darlehen aufnehmen müssen
dazu zwei zahlen die häuserpreise sind
im vergangenen jahr um über sieben
prozent gestiegen und der
durchschnittliche finanzierungs kredit
liegt inzwischen schon bei über 300.000
euro heißt das denn auch das so viel
mehr gebaut wird wie auch gebraucht wird
nein das ist ein trugschluss ist wird
zwar mehr gebaut vor allem ein- und
zweifamilienhäuser aber ausreichend ist
das nicht ihr ursprüngliches ziel
bezahlbaren wohnraum in zahlen 1,5
millionen neue wohnungen zu bauen
für die bundesregierung nämlich deutlich
verfehlt frank bethmann vielen dank
bundespräsident steinmeier hat eine
konsequente verfolgung von
sexualisierter gewalt und einen besseren
schutz von kindern und jugendlichen
gefordert
in schloss bellevue verlieh er das
bundesverdienstkreuz an matthias katsch
und pater mertes die beiden engagieren
sich seit jahren für opfer sexuellen
missbrauchs in der katholischen kirche
steinmeier erklärte es sei unerträglich
dass mächtige institutionen auch in
staat und gesellschaft den mantel des
schweigens über tausendfachen missbrauch
ausbreiteten
israel hat am heutigen jährlich
begangenen holocaust gedenktag der
jüdischen opfer des nationalsozialismus
gedacht
landesweit heulten die sirenen die
menschen hielten für zwei minuten inne
begonnen hatten die feierlichkeiten
gestern abend in der gedenkstätte jad
vaschem
zur erinnerung an die sechs millionen
jüdinnen und juden die von deutschen
ermordet worden waren
entzündeten holocaust-überlebende
fackeln aufatmen vor norwegens küste der
in seenot geratene frachter konnte von
schleppern sicher in den hafen von
alesund gebracht werden das schiff hatte
am ostermontag bei schlechtem wetter und
heftigem wellengang schlagseite bekommen
die besatzung konnte gerettet werden der
frachter drohte mit 350 tonnen schweröl
beladen auf grund zu laufen
die gefahr einer umweltkatastrophe in
sensiblen naturgebieten ist gebannt
zuschauer innen von downton abbey bis
rosamunde pilcher werden eine ziemlich
feste vorstellung haben wie eine lady zu
altern hat
schwer vorstellbar wie solche
vorstellungen den achtzigsten geburtstag
einer lady überstehen sollen die ihre
karriere als punkerin und muse der sex
pistols begonnen und sich danach nicht
verbogen hat wie viren desktop wird mit
dieser herausforderungen fertig wie sie
mit allem fertig geworden ist sie macht
vor wie es geht und gut aussieht
ja sind herrlein gratuliert aus london
von wo aus auch sonst
sie weiß selbst sehr gut wie man sich
auf dem laufsteg bewegt sie kann also
die von ihr entworfenen kleider auch
selbst tragen was ja durchaus ein
sinnvoller anspruch ist für eine
modedesignerin und dass sie nach so
vielen jahrzehnten nach wie vor zu den
allergrößten der branche zählt ist
vielleicht ihrer ganz eigenen
herangehensweise ans frauen einkleiden
zu verdanken
wenn du kleider trägt die so stark und
extrem sind wie diese sollen sie dir
helfen deine persönlichkeit
hervorzuheben
es sind kleider die dich nicht
verstecken
sie unterstützen dich versteckt hat sie
selbst sich nie die provokation hat
vivienne westwood immer dazugehört er
aber vielleicht aus der zeit als aus der
grundschullehrerin die mode queen des
punk wurde als kostüm ausstatterin des
sex pistols und ehefrau des managers der
band marke mclaren mit dem sie anfang
der 70er einen klamottenladen eröffnete
der in kürzeren abständen so aufregende
namen trug wie leidet rock oder sex
natürlich wird man sie immer mit punk in
verbindung bringt denn es gibt nur
wenige augenblicke in denen in der mode
etwas völlig neues geboren wird dies in
einklang mit musik und einer politischen
bewegung betrachtet man rein den
modischen aspekt sticht allerdings mehr
heraus was ich in den späten 80ern und
90ern tat als sie sich als
modeschöpferin neu erfand
dieser weg war gleichwohl nicht ohne
herausforderung sei es für supermodels
wie naomi campell oder die designerin
selbst gott sei dank half ihr gottschalk
einst wieder auf die plateauschuhe die
slip freie monroe anlage bei der
erhebung in den adelsstand durch die
queen war dagegen möglicherweise genau
so geplant gewesen
zu ihrem weit gefächerten freundeskreis
zählen neben prinz charles auch pamela
anderson und julian assange für die
freilassung des wikileaks gründers
engagiert sich westwood ebenso
leidenschaftlich wie für den tierschutz
für den sie sich auch gerne mal unter
die dusche stellen und den klimaschutz
ich plane eine kunstausstellung mittels
derer ich 100 millionen pfund für den
regenwald sammeln will
damit fange ich an die welt zu retten
je stärker sich vivienne westwood
politisch einbringen desto mehr hilft
die ehemalige schüler und jetziger
ehemann andreas kronthaler in ihre mode
imperium aus nach wie vor und für alle
ewigkeit wird ihr name jedoch vor allem
für eines stehen starke mode für starke
frauen heute lockern morgen lockdown ist
das thema bei maybrit illner unter
anderem mit dem saarland
ministerpräsidenten hans der lockern
will mit testen und der biologin melanie
brinkmann wie trefflich erklären kann
dass sowas voraussetzungen braucht damit
es nicht furchtbar schief geht die
sendung lohnt sich gewiss ebenso wie
unser heute-journal abdeckung nur 30
morgen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren heute war es ja
noch mal richtig kalt in mitteleuropa es
gab schneeschauer
aber jetzt machen sich die 20 grad zu
uns auf den weg sie ziehen von
südfrankreich heran und erreichen
zumindest mal baden württemberg und
bayern
aber am sonntag sehen sie dass die kalte
luft gar nicht weit von uns entfernt ist
hier im nordwesten bleibt es nämlich
richtig kalt und wenn es so große
temperaturunterschiede auf engem raum
gibt dann hängt das immer mit einem tief
zusammen wochenende überquert uns einst
hier von der bild anja zieht es der hand
und sieht weiter richtung ostsee und
auch am sonntag kommt schon wieder ein
neues die hinterher
das liegt dann über paris und das bringt
sogar noch mal schnee mit in dieser
nacht allerdings fällt aus wolken
höchstens regen heraus nämlich in
nordfriesland süden es ist dagegen klar
unter den dichteren wolken nordwesten
bleibt es recht mild mit 5 bis 1 grad im
süden dagegen sinken die werte auf minus
ein bis minus sieben grad und obwohl es
so klapper kaltes nachts wird es
tagsüber doch sehr mit 13 bis 19 grad
erwarten uns in süddeutschland im norden
sind es nur 8 bis 13 grad
dort sind dichte wolken unterwegs und
die bringen hier zwischen der
ostseeküste und norderney auch regen mit
aber weiter richtung süden zeigt sich
doch immer häufiger die sonne und das
bei südwestwind
am samstag kommt dann schon das erste
tieferen bringt kräftigen regen im
westen bei temperaturen von acht bis 17
grad und am sonntag gibt es dann diese
wetter zweiteilung also im nordwesten
ist es kühl bei regen steigen die werte
nur auf sechs grad im südosten sind es
dagegen 20 grad bei viel sonne und in
der neuen woche kommt die kälte auch am
alpenrand an schönen abend noch